انت درست في اسطنبول يعني تخصصت
بالحروفيات باسطنبول تخصصت بالخط التقليدي
الخاص
لماذا اسطنبول لانه فيها مدارس يعني لنكن
منصفين
او اكثر عم نحكي مثلا انا اخذت من استاذي
علي اللي هو اخذ من استاذ حليم بيك اللي
اخذ هو نذهب
الى عمق الف 1200 سنه او اكثر فهذا شيء
ليس سهل هذا والتاصيل الحرف وتدريس الحرف
بشكل اكاديمي عندهم موجود وليس موجود
بالحرف العربي وهم يعني بيكتبوا بحرفيني
يعني تركيا موضوع مختلف وشائك لانه كل شخص
له مرجعيته
الملتزمون مثلا يتجهون الى الخط التقليدي
اما مثلا
العلمانيون
والحداثويون عندهم قطيعه مع الحرف لانه
يريدون عن كل ما سبق يعني كل شيء يذكرهم
بهذا الموروث هم بيغنوا لكن قسم كبير من
الاتراك ينظر الى الحرف بقدسيه الان يعني
عندما يرى لوحه فهو امام نص مقدس ان كان
حتى لو لم يكن النص ديني
[موسيقى]